mademoiselle monsieur bonjour je sais
que vous avez tous passés les bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année est aujourd'hui cf
demain c'est l'épiphanie le jour des
rois
et pour le jour des rois à côté de moi
le roi des nuits parisiennes jean marie
rivière merci vous qui est de notre pays
tuez-nous exactement berges
d'hébergement bergeaud et à bergerac
pour le jour des rois on mange pas la
galette parisienne feuilletée on manque
quoi la grosse galette briochée la
couronne des rois avec décédera dans du
fric en avion alors nous on a acheter
des fruits confits en vrac en a 100 g
qu'on a coupé en petits morceaux et
j'ajoute dont ses fruits confits quoi le
fleur d'orange publié en soupe d'eau de
fleur d'oranger
je sais que toi tu préfèrerais que gym
est ce qu'on y met chez nous aussi on va
pas dire le nom disons de l'apéritif
anisé un oui mais c'est pour les
environs du parc en souvenir de jeunesse
d'or et on laisse doucement cette ses
fruits confits macérer dans la fleur
d'oranger ici devant nous une casserole
on va s'allumer le feu atteint bout je
pars tu me poses la casserole sur le feu
dans cette casserole qu'est-ce que je
mets du lait trois quarts de verre de
lait c'est prêcher du léon m21 que vous
servirez antennes deux messagers
comprendre pourquoi il ya du fromage le
beurre
nous savons tout n 2 de l'armagnac
antenne 2 du mulet antenne 2 toute
antenne 2 mai paraît qu'à d'excellents
fromages oui oui monsieur vous nous
regardez deux grosse pincée de sel 1dans
seul et j'ajoute 75 g de beurre que je
coupe en petits morceaux et puis je vais
ajouter également neuf morceaux de sucre
la femme pas un de plus 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 je baisse le feu doux et là qu'est ce
qui va se passer le sucre la fondre le
beurre à fondre
tu vas me remuer tout ça et quand s'est
bien fondu
tu étais le feu regardez devant moi j'ai
de la levure de boulanger le paquet de
levure de boulanger pèse 40 g j'en
prends un peu moins de la moitié
c'est-à-dire 15 grammes que je mets ici
dans un petit comment s'appelle un petit
saladier n'importe quoi et devant moi
j'ai de l'eau tiède
j'ajoute une belle cuillère à soupe
d'eau tiède
donc ce cette levure et avec mon petit
doigt
j'essaye de mélanger tout ça en fait
pour faire fondre la levure dans l'eau
tiède
est ce que ce sera fait en côte est est
ce que le sucre est fondu tu dois me
sentir
oui je le seul à sentir city hunter
cutting qu'avec marin vas-y vas-y bouge
pas voilà ça y est tu laisses un petit
et dire quoi bon ça y est moi j'ai
mélangé ici j'ai comme d'habitude le
doigt salle
tout cela ce que tu sais ce qu'est ce
que nous utilisons la com farine comme
farine on utilise de la type e 55 et la
farine qu'on prouve tout le boulanger
tous les boulangers et la regarde je
fais on trouve au milieu de cette farine
1 dans un puits et puis dans ce puis-je
verse quoi mon petit mélange de levure
fondu avec mono tiède et puis je vais
ajouter 2 cuillères à soupe de sucre en
poudre
n'oublions pas la fèvre non non non
va pas l'oublier et puis je remets
toujours je vais rêve tout ça grâce au
prêt je vais ajouter 2 1 et 2 2
et puis qu'est-ce que je vais faire
maintenant je vais commencer à mélanger
le tout pouvoir les fruits confits on va
les mettre qu'on va les mettre là
maintenant une fois que j'ai mélangé tu
vas me verser avec ton habileté habituel
le mélange de lait de sucre ses
casseroles c'est pas facile vas-y d'un
coup et c'est vraiment du plaisir que je
vois à l'armée j'ajoute mans des rues qu
elle va bien et cela n'est pas mauvaise
on sait la gardera pour la prochaine
fois j'ajoute immédiatement mes fruits
confits et voilà comme ça et puis je
vais commencer à mélanger avec la main
et puis qui va le voir il arrive un
moment où v avec la cuillère en bois et
respectueux et puis à un moment où je
peux plus mélanger avec la cuillère en
bois où il faut que je mélange avec la
main à temps ça va y être là et alors
c'est la partie chercher pour ça que je
dis que c'est une émission pour les
enfants car les enfants adorent tout ce
qui est sale donc je re et et ça ça
réunit tout ça tu comprends dans la
mesure où on a à mettre au four c'est
dangereux car on peut se brûler et ça le
45 mais un peu partout alors je retrouve
mon boulot vers sa fille fayard le télé
alors j'obtiens un truc qui est tous
nous tu vois et et s'accroche au doigt
alors qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
il va falloir à partir de maintenant que
je batte cette pâte tu vois comme ceci
jusqu'à ce qu' elle ne me colle plus au
doigt du tout
et pour faire à cette opération il va me
falloir jusqu'à ce qu'elle fera le plus
audois n'ont pas de farine justement
entre cinq et sept minutes qui voit en
la battant comme ça et dans 5 à 7
minutes on se retrouve avec une pâte qui
le verra sera devenu
non koh lanta mais doit alors voilà
regarde il nous a fallu cinq minutes et
on obtient tu vois une pâte qui colle
plus alors regarde bien ce que je vais
faire
tu te souviens dans les foires comment
ça ça te laisse à tous les niveaux de
bim de guînes me regarda ça alors on va
être là sa wii et tisser du lien des
films de tati
oui toujours le train devait tomber et
avait essayé de se précipiter pour
l'attraper
regardez on dirait régime dans le bourg
à 10 dont je pose ça comme ça je donne
ici une petite rico tour pour bien
soudés ensemble et là j'ai des ciseaux à
côté de moi je prends mes ciseaux rien
ce que je fais sur la pâte qui me suis
bien là où je suis oui c'est pour lui
permettre de laisser ce secteur houiller
de me dire mon intuition la faire alors
véritable feu je prends une véritable
fèves up jeu l'enfoncent là dedans je
referme je redonne un petit coup chuck
est maintenant alors là ce que je vous
dirais très très important il va falloir
la faire reposer cette galette
cette galette cette couronne trois
heures dans un endroit tiède de
l'appartement couvertes dans le linge
comme ceux ci et là s'il te plaît tu vas
me chercher là bas au dessus
oui une galette une galette une couronne
qui a trois heures de repos c'est la
même
on l'a fait juste avant l'émission quant
à qu'on regardait la voilà celle que
nous venons de faire elle va durer trois
heures au bout de trois heures
ah ah merci merci pour vos
applaudissements
à partir de là qu'est ce qu'on fait on
met cette couronne au four thermostat 6
c'est à dire 180 degrés pour une demi
heure et une demi heure après nous
allons chercher la couronne et qui
prêtent attention ce n'est pas terminé
je vais chercher la couronne partance
pour pas me brûler et regardez ce que je
vais faire
regarde la sienne est belle une
demi-heure après bien dorée alors là
devant moi j'ai dans une petite
casserole fait fondre du sucre 2
cuillères à soupe de sucre et 2
cuillères à soupe d'eau de tartines le
dessus de ma couronne avec ce mélange de
sucre et d'eau pourquoi est ce que je
fais ça jean marie est ce que tu veux
mettre quelque chose de si je vais
mettre quelque chose dessus et je veux
que ce quelque chose comme dessus et ce
sera tout simplement du sucre
cristallisé en morceaux qu'on a écrasé
tue ca reichmann ouais c'est ça de voir
exactement du sucre cassonade
alors là je prends du sucre cassonade
comme tu dis si bien je le mets un peu
dessus partout et je vais remettre ma
galette mccall est ma couronne toujours
à four thermostat 6 pour cinq minutes de
plus de cette façon le sucre que j'ai
tartiner dessus va redevenir dur et les
petits morceaux de sucre vont coller
alors je la remets et je te demande si
tu te plais oui de me dire à quel moment
ces cinq minutes seront passées et tant
que je suis là je vous rappelle les
proportions de la couronne des rois
il nous a fallu trois quarts de verre de
lait c'est à dire quinze centilitres 550
g de farine 15 g de levure du boulanger
une cuillère à soupe d'eau de fleur
d'oranger neuf morceaux de sucre c'est
pas la peine de rajouter les deux
cuillères que j'ai mise mois 75 g de
beurre 2 oeufs 2 pincées de sel et nous
a fallu également 100 grammes de fruits
confits nous a fallu une belle fais bien
sûr et un peu d'eau et un peu de sucre
pour faire notre petit truc dessus avec
le sucre cassonade
bon alors maintenant la galette
feuilletée parisienne alors le
feuilletage le feuille de match c'est un
tout est pratiquement impossible à faire
la maison et puis j'ai trouvé dans un
vieux livre une recette de feuilletage
très spécial et qui marche très bien
regarder devant moi de la farine que
j'ai réalisé que c'est une seconde un
peu pour qu'il y ait pas de grumeaux
je fais toujours pareil le lui de la
vérité au milieu et dans ce puits
qu'est-ce que je n'ai je mets une deux
pincées de sel
j'ajoute une 2 cuillères à soupe de
sucre en poudre
c'est celle que j'avais mis tout à
l'heure dans votre recette mais allez
pas et puis j'ajoute 25 centilitres
d'eau s'il vous plaît notez bien tout ce
que je dis là car les quantités son
capital et ne peuvent pas changer 25
centilitres d'eau pour 600 g ferry pour
600 g de farine et puis là avec la
cuillère en bois
j'adore ça quand ça commence à les
entourer de la colle à ses meilleurs ça
tu vas voir
et là j'ai également devant moi 350 g de
beurre bien ramolli attention avec ces
quantités là on va obtenir deux énormes
galette des rois alpes a eu deux énormes
galette des rois
et là je crois parce que je parais on
était alors à prêt à me dis qu'à cinq
minutes attend bouge pas je ne bouge pas
la galette vite la voilà la couronne des
rois regard des passages suffirait que
je suis content alors là on va se
dépêcher
on va mettre ça sur un plat regardez la
bien cette couronne des rois pour la
décrocher d'ivoire elle est un petit peu
regardé ça
oh tu la pose un peu là bas j'en arrive
sur notre table d'ivoire bout et puis
nous on continue dans notre grande série
la potasse car on y arrive on comprend
précis où je vais plonger ma main là
dedans et oui et ou alors cela je crois
comme toi ne te serais ravi et de
regarder ça et là à le dire ici et on va
obtenir une boule de pâte complètement
molle car le beurre bien sûr et très
ramolli
alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire comme ça
on aura obtenu cette boule de pâte très
ramolli
tu vas me le dire et b la fin lors la
mettre au réfrigérateur tu vois pour
qu'elle durcisse un peu pour qu'elle
dure alors là tu vois me faut quand même
un tout petit peu plus de farine alors
je vais te demander avec cette cuillère
il ajouter 2 cuillères à soupe de farine
a un plan bien pleine
carla attend encore une voie là ça
dépend aussi de votre farine jeu là
relativement coûteuse parce que 359 e
350 g de beurre comme ça vaut le kilo
pour deux galettes de six personnes oui
et non moi je veux bien que ce soit trop
coûteux mais c'est pas très vrai tu vas
encore une cuillère s'il te plait merci
hélas j'obtiens une belle boule de pâte
molle et la caisse que j'ai devant moi
une assiette dans cette assiette t on un
peu de farine au fond voilà je pose ma
boule de pâte est déçu voilà tu me remet
un peu de farine dessus s'il te plaît
voilà
et là qui va reporter cette pâte au
frigo pour une demi heure et il y en a
une qui a déjà une demi heure que tu me
ramènes là haut
voilà voilà
alors merci alors regardez la boule de
pâte a durci maintenant bon je vais
aller me laver les mains valeur regarde
ce que tu as devant toi toi qu'est ce
que tu as devant toi j'ai 80 g
80 g de poudre d'amandes 80 gr mauvais
c'était 80 g de sucre en poudre et 1,9
alors ça c'est la face tu vois pour ma
mère dans alors qu'ils me casser l'oeuf
dans le saladier
tu ajoutes le sucre en poudre et petits
ne blanchit tout ça tu vois avec ton
fouet et pendant ce temps là je me lave
les mains et je reviens vas-y je te
surveille un oui ça marche tout seul
ajoute une petite pincée de sel dans ces
cas trouve devant toi j'en arrive là on
voit pas et là je vais te donner toutes
les raptors arrive c'est pas grave
est-ce que ça de l'anssi ça commence
ceci étant dit si ça blanchit pas c'est
que votre téléviseur depuis réglé
non seulement ça y est ça bien
j'arrive intel quelque part est superbe
on sait bien ce truc là parce que
autrefois l'avant la guerre il fallait
écrire salle a pu hier alors regarde
tout va baisser sur la vitesse indiquée
sur petite vitesse voilà je t'ajoute 80
g de beurre bien ramolli tulle incorpore
doucement et tu te remets à nouveau
quand il est incorporé sûr
attends je te mets la poudre d'amandes
maintenant juillet 80 g de poudre
d'amandes du même corps port tout ça et
qui repasse sur grande vitesse et
pendant ce temps là moi je continue et à
l'appui que personne ne regardait commis
à côté tu es tu regardes la farine sur
la table la patte sur la table et là
je farine n'a pas ça y est tu peux
arrêter tout arrêter stop stop stop stop
stop stop stop
voilà alors la regarde ce qu'on va faire
on va donner un petit coup ici et tu
comprends bien que cette crème est trop
liquide 1 pour l'instant il faudra tout
à l'heure la mener au réfrigérateur avec
la place pour qu'elle durcisse la pata
regarde comment elle est devenue assez
dur pour que je puisse l'étaler sans
problème en lorrain alors un peu de
farine dessous chaque été c'est
peut-être un peu dessus la haie on y va
gaiement
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on à faire on
parlait tout à l'heure de sarlat du
collège sarlat que tu connais bien où
moi j'ai passé une partie de ma jeunesse
studio on va faire un lit en
portefeuille
souviens-toi très bien alors regarde je
repli en trois autres comme ceux ci
comme ceci là je tourne la patte d'un
quart de tour vers moi qui a bien suivi
je referme à pattes et là je recommence
un chausseur a étalé voilà et qu'est ce
qui se passe plus je vais faire deux
tours c'est à dire plus je vais mettre
des pêcheurs plus je vais faire de
feuilles en fait et c'est ça qu'on
appelle la pâte feuilletée
c'est le nombre de feuilles superposés
qui à la cuisson vont se séparer les
unes des autres et gonflé je connaissais
beaucoup plus compliqué la vraie pâte
feuilletée c'est plus compliqué car il
faut que le beurre soit mis en morceaux
dedans mais pour une galette des rois
ça monte admirablement alors la regarde
deuxième fois la voilà la un plat
un peu de farine dans ce plat ma patte
posée dessus un peu de farine dessus
air-air ce que je fais deux et il y en a
une au frigo attendez je mets ça pour
une demi heure au réfrigérateur pour que
ça dure six encore à nouveau et tu vas
me chercher celle qui a deux fois repris
j l
allons-y gaiement la voile alors même
chose les enfants alors je vais mettre
ça au frigo tue pas formidable un
formidable je repose ma patte devant moi
voyez le petit 2 qui hélas est à nouveau
à cause d'une erreur non je vous le
montre bien
pour que vous sachiez puissiez plus
jamais vous trompez pour faire à ce
style de patin qui marche
admirablement alors vous étalez le plus
également possible car sinon qu'est-ce
qui se passerait à la cuisson les
endroits où s'est arrêté plus gros que
d'autres tu aurais tu vois des l'etna
d'un côté et le gouffre de padirac de
l'autre ce qui n'est pas le but
recherché est là quand j'ai fait ça par
un coup deux coups un quart de tour tu
vois c'est facile à nouveau je crois que
le champagne sera le bienvenu tout à
leur dire et là ça y est on y voit
combien de fun et b où il y en a
beaucoup
aujourd'hui il ya là un petit couleurs
ce sens est un peu dur tu vois elle est
restée un peu longtemps mais c'est pas
grave
et là je repli hop hop
dans le plat un peu de farine dessus un
peu de farine et je fais top top et au
frigo pour une dernière
ouf et ça y est on va être prêt à faire
la galette des rois
dans quelques secondes puis m'attrape
celle qu'il ya quatre tours merci alors
la foule
dis donc ça nous donne chaud je vais
pour la dernière fois
tu vas me vers le petit il est fou un
petit verdot un jour d'épiphanie et en
titre compte de ce côté dit alors ça je
vous le montre pas je vais la replier
encore une fois des jours le monde quand
même
hop hop et maintenant je vais lui talent
et à la taille précise et on se retrouve
quand il est italien
attends attends tu vois rien j'ai étalé
seulement la moitié de la pâte 1 l'autre
moitié c'est pour une autre galette
alors regarde je prends une assiette qui
sera la taille de ma galette et je
regarde si j'ai deux portions oui je les
ai alors la traque
je partage en deux tu me suis un jusqu'à
maintenant bon et l'âme avoir les bras
pour faire tout ça n'est pas trop
d'enfants très jeunes repoussent une
partie de cette pâte très bien et là je
vais rouler cette pâte sur un rouleau à
pâtisserie 10 voix pour ceux ci en la
décrochant au fur et à mesure en cas les
accrocher je prends la plaque du four
je déroule c'est facile jusque là sur la
plaque du four
et là je retrace un peu mon tour tu vois
juste mais sans faire de sens surtout
couper un regarde je retrace un peu mon
tour avec une cuillère comme ça
et là qui va me chercher s'il te plaît
au réfrigérateur
là la crème que tu as fait cette crème à
l'amande absolument sublime que tu m'as
fret alors regarde on va létale et
maintenant tu vois les parfaites et nous
a fallu que dix minutes of rigoureux
alors on étale comme ça tu vois en a
fait de la crème que pour une tarte à
jeudi bien que pour une galette
si vous voulez refaire la deuxième même
galette vous remettez pour fait
exactement là la crème que jean marie a
fait 7 avec lunettes pour laquelle j'ai
employé 80 g de sucre en poudre 80 g de
beurre plus il le mérite il a dit d'une
façon superbe
n'oublions pas le faire non tiens c'est
vrai j'allais l'oublier évident alors là
on va se mettre un petit baigneur à ce
coup ci n ont pas ce que tu veux je me
teins brunet véritable fleuve héritière
d'un truc est là mais tous les quatre
comme ça alors maintenant j'ai devant
moi un avis à temps m si ça s'était mal
pour vous qu'est ce que le petit bol et
regarde chez le bart melek
parce qu'il va falloir que je soude mais
deux parties l'une à l'autre puisque je
vais recouvrir avec la pâte et là je
vais me tartiner tu vois j'ai tracé un
peu le beurre on le voit bien
je vais me tartiner le bords de la pâte
avec l'oeuf battu
et puis
voilà tu vois tu suis bien là j'ai pas
c'est pas compliqué je vais prendre la
deuxième partie de ma patte la rouler
sur mon truc là et là déroulé tu vois tu
as compris et là qu'est ce que je fais
soigneusement je soude mais deux parties
l'une à l'autre
et maintenant je reprends cette fameuse
assiette je la pose à l'envers dessus et
là d'un coup d'un seul
car c'est pas la peine de le faire deux
fois tu comprends je fais le tour de ma
patte et ça vous allez refaire ça c'est
pour les enfants parce qu'ils ont su r
ouais on peut en faire à l'infini et
c'est pour la deuxième partie tu vois on
regarde la deuxième partie qu'on a gardé
on va en faire encore plus bon
maintenant qu'est-ce que je vais faire
tout autour je vais rentrer un peu ma
patte qui voit juste comme ça pas
beaucoup et puis je vais faire au milieu
je menais une cheminée une cheminée
la voilà parce que cette pâte à la
tendance à gonfler beaucoup à la cuisson
est ce que vous pouvez faire aussi sur
la partie du bas s'est piquée avec la
fourchette pour qu'elle gonfle pas un
trop alors là avec notre oeuvre
il y en a pour les deux galettes on va
doré là un jeu non à l'oeuf
c'est beau quand même ça c'est déjà
assez déjà arrêté ça on va les faire
après parce que si on les faisait avant
qu est ce qui se passerait avec leur
bébé disparaîtrait tu comprends alors y
serait caché tandis que là ils vont être
bien beau tu vas voir derrière le
saint-cyr volts et voilà alors la
regarde maintenant je vais te faire les
petits dessins comment les faits temps
comme ça tout simplement
hop hop
hop c'est fou hein quand même ce qu'on
arrive à faire avec un kit son voyage à
et cette tarte cette tarte cette galette
vous allez me la mettre au four
thermostat 7 et demi c'est à dire cette
fois de 3,21 220° pour 20 minutes au
bout de 20 minutes qui me passent à
celle qu'elle a regardé ce que vous
allez obtenir et que nous allons goûter
devant vos yeux ébloui
alors on va passer à table tu prends
cette tarte
je prends l'autre là je prends la voix
la superbe couronne je rappelle vas-y
vatable ma table va table je rappelle la
galette des rois les proportions pour
deux galettes des rois 600 g de farine
350 g de beurre ramolli 25 centilitres
d'eau 2 cuillères à soupe de sucre en
poudre
une pincée de sel ça c'est pour les deux
patins et puis pour l'intérieur d'une
seule 80 g de sucre en poudre 80 g de
beurre 1 9 80 g de poudre d'amandes une
pincée de sel une fève ne l'oublié pas
et puis pour dorer vos deux galettes il
nous faut également un oeuf et la voilà
j'avais peu de débouchés les débouchés
non attendue elle a sabré sa couleur du
sable je te coupe jeu très coupe
orphée formidable regardez moi ici
pendant ce temps soit je vous sers
heureux de dire deux choses c'est pas la
peine un bon couteau
non ça vient pas regarder sa jambe a le
regard de moi c'est toi
assieds toi je vais te couper maintenant
regarde la tarte la tarte la galette des
rois feuilletée
avec la crème d'amande dedans auquel
regarder si elle est belle
tiens goûtez moi ça t'as pas besoin de
porter ce que tu prenais chez toi ce que
tu prends une fourchette regarder ça et
là est ce qu'on a le temps de parler on
peut pas parler de la galette des rois
ge est difficile de parler je vais la
douve touch est traîtresse merci de nous
avoir écoutés une bonne épiphanie demain
beaucoup de galettes des rois remercions
les rois mages de nous avoir amélioré de
se ramener tout ça merci wanamaker
dernier gaspard gaspard merci gaspard à
dimanche prochain à samedi prochain
[Musique]